you've made some pretty specific
allegations about what Russia is doing
with mercenaries uh Etc in in your
country what exactly are you telling um
your allies here about that in detail
what the Russians are doing and how does
it compare to what they've been doing in
Ukraine since 2014
if you look at the model that Russia has
used in invading parts of Ukraine in
2014 that's exactly the model that
Serbia has been trying to use in the
western Balkans but particularly in
Kosovo for the past couple of months so
they abuse minority communities they try
to create false flag operations they
build trenches within our territory they
bring in paramilitary forces that are
dressed in civilians within our
territory through illegal routes and
then they send them weapons and they
also send them green uniforms without
Insignia so that it doesn't look like a
traditional military attack but in fact
they do prepare a lot of hybrid attacks
which is a mix of what these
paramilitary forces do in Northern
Kosovo we shouldn't be talking about
these kind of things when it becomes too
late it's very important for me as
president of the country to inform our
allies what exactly is happening in the
ground and then not to end up after a
couple of years sitting in the
negotiation table and say oh this is the
factual situation in the ground so let's
talk about what piece of your territory
we should give to Serbia genocidal
regime should not be should not be
awarded with territory I mean broadening
it away from not just Kosovo but Moldova
for other countries what is Vladimir
Putin up to do you think what's he
planning to do away from Ukraine we've
heard about accusations you may be
trying to widen the conflict what's his
game here the unity that the
transatlantic Community has shown when
it comes to Ukraine obviously doesn't go
in Russia's interest so I believe that
what he's trying to do is to divert the
attention of the West away from Ukraine
the way how he would be able to do that
is create other conflicts in Europe
whether we're talking about Moldova or
Georgia or the Western Balkans it would
go towards Russia's interests to make
sure that the attention of the West is
kind of everywhere instead of just
focused on Ukraine which rightly is
right now so that's what they're trying
to do which is why we need to prevent
them together from from doing exactly
that and is that threat being taken
seriously here do you think look
sometimes we feel just like
when Poland and the baltics we're
warning that this is exactly what's
going to happen many many years ago that
Russia is going to go with a full-scale
invasion of Ukraine and not just Ukraine
because they see other neighbors as
temporary States
they were not being listened to and
sometimes when we speak up when Bosnia
speaks up when Montenegro speaks up
about this big danger that needs to be
prevented now before it becomes too late
we feel exactly like the baltics and
Poland many years ago so this is not
just about Kosovo someone should not
think oh it's a tiny country why should
we look at that why should be worried
it's about all of us the same way that
Ukraine today is about all of us
instability in one country in Europe
means instability in all so having a
peaceful Western Balkans is a
contribution towards a Europe hold free
at and at peace it's a contribution for
a piece of a peaceful life for Citizens
living in the UK or living in let's say
in Poland or somewhere else so that's
why working together in this is so
crucial unity in protecting the Western
Balkans from these malign influences is
as key as unity in Ukraine is today and
finally your thoughts for the year ahead
we've had a terrible year do you think
the worst is over in Ukraine
if we when I say we I of course mainly
mean the strongest countries in terms of
military capabilities do not give
Ukraine the the kind of help that they
need
um the war will continue but when I say
the world will continue I don't mean
just Ukraine Russia will be encouraged
to attack others as well mostly their
first neighbors but the war needs to end
with Ukraine winning that's the only end
otherwise it's just a continuation or a
postponement as we have seen from the
2014 events